do you think people realize how hard
crowdfunding is I mean it's Kickstarter
and IndieGoGo there's such sexy sites
and they see these beautiful trailers do
you think people just think oh I'll just
put this up and then strangers from all
over the world will find my I think
that's exactly what people think and
they're wrong and people do that and
they you see a lot of things that don't
that don't make their goal like what was
it you found a great one that was a
great project you know I backed and I
tweeted about it and I went back a
couple of days later and they didn't
have any more backers and then went back
a couple weeks later and they didn't
have any more backers I was like that
means to me that they didn't even put in
the effort to con their friends into
backing their project which means that
maybe they should look into how
crowdfunding works some more and try
again because it's almost a full-time
job yeah there's a lot of refreshing of
the the webpage yeah and our first one
was definitely a full-time job and and
so is this one it's really hard and you
have to do a lot of research and you
have to do a lot of contacting people
and blogs and you know newspapers and
things that aren't ever gonna contact
you back but you have to contact them
anyway and just in case and it's it's
very difficult and you have to have a
base to start with - I read somewhere
that you know your number of Facebook
friends is directly proportional to how
well your Kickstarter does and Facebook
is definitely the number one source for
our pledges so attractive yeah since
last year Kickstarter put in a great new
dashboard and you can see where
everything's come from coming from so
that's a great time-waster - because you
can look at that but let go so you know
37% from Twitter I but I better tweet
more so right mostly it's just trying to
get the word out and trying to get
people to repost retweets and that sort
of thing with because that's it's really
eyeballs getting eyeballs on the project
on the video because if they liked the
video then then that's good and
explaining to people that even if you
don't have money into pledge which I
totally understand sharing it is worth
something yes you tweeted a few Facebook
it and then if you do that again in a
couple days that really helps the people
and I do that a lot with projects that
I'm not gonna back I'll share them
because I think they're wonderful and I
want them to happen so and having new
content to post so give me not posting
the same thing over and over again
really helps we were a little pressed
for time with this with this one we
would have preferred to have had a
couple of different videos ready to go
so we could you know release them we did
a second video after with Barry Bostwick
who's in the movie that was it was a lot
of fun and we have a couple written but
you know it's been hard to apply
people's schedules up so it would have
been nice if we were smart to play more
time you have to have had the whole
campaign we had to pull stronger because
of the timing of our of our first
screenings yeah so what do you found has
been the biggest draw besides Facebook
to getting people that are outside your
social circle family and friends to
donate what's been the best approach
well for our last Kickstarter we were
very lucky to get a lot of blog
attention and that definitely was what
yeah every time we got will feature a
new blog like Boing Boing or Nerdist or
things Gizmodo
alone I think squid it would just they
were just surged because it was it was
eyeballs on it that hadn't seen it
before and that people were excited
about the idea and it also had the
legitimacy of an outside source saying
hey look at this thing as opposed to the
person themselves yeah right Hey look at
me already yeah so that really really
helped and in terms of we're not having
the same sort of media attention having
Barry Bostwick
retweet and or
that doesn't have a Twitter but
facebooking sharing the the video that
he did really helped me okay man shared
it which was helpful yeah Simon Helberg
who's in the movie shared it which is
helpful and just having anyone share it
is helpful
anyone with reach we we had a little
article in The Nerdist today yeah and
there was a definite there's been a bump
today that really went along with that
we were featured and we were did an
interview on the Nerdist on Friday that
land that landed and and that give us a
little bit of a bump as well so it's
it's just about getting the word out and
yeah people people hearing your message
and hopefully it'll like what you have
to say well what sounds good in theory
but then it actually didn't work too
well huh um well I'll look at the
Kickstarter oh gosh there hasn't been a
pledge for four hours and I'll go and
and do a lot of social media and nothing
happens so it's really hard to know what
doesn't work yeah what else doesn't work
what else doesn't work oh I sent an
email to every single person from that
is on my facebook from my hometown and I
people just don't read Facebook messages
is part of it
but I think I got one response so that
you know people say personal appeals
that I think emails may be better than
Facebook messages bowls foam gaps okay
text messages explaining to your
grandmother how to open her email so she
can share this with her then do you
think there are certain times of day
that are more receptive to tweets I mean
I know David's always said five o'clock
seems like a good time is that yeah and
I noticed in the morning too which is
terrible you have to get up and
we like to work late yeah that's the
problem too is a lot of times 3 a.m. I'm
tweeting and facebooking up a storm and
nobody cares sure that there's people in
Germany yeah yes yes our foreign to a
nice land we have the abandoned
Indonesia yes true the vehicle that film
is played there
you